condena fui firme y unánime por parte de
los 27 líderes de la Unión Europea han
asegurado que condenan rápidamente esta
esta agresión por parte de Rusia
consideran que es una violación más al
territorio de al territorio ucraniano
que es una violación más también a su
soberanía los 27 han subrayado que el
territorio anexonado no se va a
reconocer piden a la comunidad
internacional que haga lo mismo y que
tampoco reconozca a estos territorios
del este de Ucrania igual que tampoco
reconocieron la anexión de la Península
de crimea en 2014 la para la Unión
Europea está anexión ilegal Se produce
después de un referéndum considerado
además también y legal y que es una
forma de Rusia de acercar la guerra a su
territorio pero que aún así la Unión
Europea está dispuesta a seguir ayudando
a Ucrania tal y como la ha hecho ahora
con ayuda humanitaria también con ayuda
militar y financiera Rusia consideran
desde la Unión Europea que con este
movimiento sigue amenazando aún más la
seguridad mundial ante la situación los
países dicen que están dispuestos a
probar nuevas sanciones recordemos ya
están negociando un octavo paquete que
se espera que se pueda aprobar en los
próximos días pero dicen que no les
temblará el pulso para seguir aprobando
nuevas sanciones